en lo que fue la primera visita en 11
años de un presidente o presidenta de la
comisión Europea el mandatario mexicano
Andrés Manuel López Obrador recibió en
Palacio Nacional a Úrsula bonderlayen en
un comunicado conjunto posterior al
encuentro privado se informó que ambos
líderes convinieron en acelerar las
negociaciones del acuerdo global
modernizado este acuerdo que existe
entre México y la Unión Europea pero que
Data de 1997 y que va más allá de lo
estrictamente comercial pues abarca la
cooperación y el diálogo político los
presidentes también se pronunciaron por
fortalecer las inversiones recíprocas y
en ese sentido celebraron que se haya
firmado una declaración conjunta de
intención entre el gobierno de México y
el banco europeo de inversiones para
fortalecer la estrategia de
financiamiento sostenible de México
hablaron también de temas prioritarios
tanto para México como para la Unión
Europea y como la estrategia global
Gateway puede ofrecer oportunidades en
distintos ámbitos Como por ejemplo salud
pública producción de vacunas energías
sostenibles y el manejo sustentable del
agua entre otros temas también se
comprometieron a combatir el tráfico
ilícito de armas ligeras y pequeñas y
puntualizaron la necesidad de abordar un
enfoque integral para atender la
migración finalmente expresaron su
solidaridad con el pueblo ucraniano ante
la invasión rusa y apoyaron su soberanía
e independencia